yeah cool okay great that that works I
think like there's like tiny bit of the
screen that's cut up cut off at both
ends I don't think it's gonna be a
problem just like yeah just tell me if
something is completely not
understandable yeah anyway I'm Anna I
don't know like whether you're all
morning people I'm not I I I'm not
usually awake at that kind of time so
yeah I hope this is going well it's not
going to be a like it's going to be a
technical talk about node just like yeah
okay so first of all first of all like
the forward he doesn't work here so I'm
gonna have to go here
okay so Who am I Anna I'm a DBA LAX on
Twitter and github / answered whatever
you want I use she/her pronouns and I've
been an active contributor to know chess
since December 2015
it's like quite a while ago and I'm and
I know just to see like technical
steering committee and what that means
is that I am one of the people who like
if there is no consensus among the you
know chess collaborator group where the
people who decide what actually happens
or we try to set the the general
direction for where the project is going
like that that also means that like if
you want to complain about something or
anything you can like I personally can
come to and it's like I'm gonna start
this start by like describing how I
originally got into coding in Noches I'm
contributing to know chess itself and so
like there's this I hope you can you all
read that I not that's what so like
basically it's like setting using
timeout with like invalid parameters
using the like accidentally passing a
number twice and like don't ask me why I
did that I I had something like that in
my code once and like I couldn't really
figure out where wearing that coat that
was means like that was the original
stack race that you were getting and I'm
still I just don't think you're getting
it unknown far and so yeah just like
it's it's blowing up when it tries to
call that function which is 1000 which
is not a function so it's not going to
work and so like yeah that was
frustrating to debug and actually the
the easiest way that I could think of
debugging this was like to actually
patch note card so that it would like
throw an error if if the function first
the timeout is not actually function so
like this is I mean there were tests and
there were what's the documentation
change and everything it like with this
but basically this was all the patch to
us like if the callbacks not a function
then like complain immediately so you
would get a proper stack trace and yeah
and like i mentioning this because like
it's it's just that a like no jess is
part of your application if you build
something in note so it means like every
improvement that you make to note makes
your code better and like if there is
something that you think that note could
do better
you can like try to come up with a pull
request or maybe even choose open issue
or something it's a lot of these small
things that that actually make note a
great software like for example like
after he like seven or eight last pull
requests that I opened like two were
actual bug fixes for like HTTP to stuff
and the like five of them were just like
stuff that I ran along the way while I
was debugging them just like thinking
okay yeah this is not helpful what note
does their so let's do something more
helpful okay yeah so why was I talking
about that and like why I'm talking
about no chase in general it's not just
because like I'm a core contributor it's
also because like before I made that
patch and like before later I started
watching the no J
no repository and everything I didn't
really have a lot of a lot of concept
about what was going on inside the court
no just community it's kind of like it
was kind of like its own separate world
and and I know that a lot of people in
the community still feel kind of
disconnected from from what's happening
there like most of you probably just
like take the releases of notice they
come and like update every once in a
while and sometimes hear about new cool
features or something but but basically
that's it and like I think it would be
cool for both sides if they're like if
people had more of an idea what was
happening a note and if we note core
people have more of an idea what was
what what users actually do it need any
like it's not like none of us are
actually are aren't users either but you
know okay so and where are we now with
note as to like no tennis just around
the corner it's probably going to come
out in April until yesterday I thought
it was definitely coming out in April
[Laughter]
okay yeah so I'm gonna like maybe
mention that later but yeah probably so
like what's gonna have its features like
yes modules which yet excited like too
early it's like I probably can't speak
as much to it as I should because like I
try to stay away from that topic because
like it's
it's not it's not like healthy to like
talk about it a lot
htv-2 which is like a lot more fun and
which like I'm participating in a lot
more icing hooks which you may have
heard of might probably not have used
but like it's pretty cool thing and
people are building pretty cool things
with it and yeah you're gonna want to
know about that an API just like also
very very specific it's just like for
native add-on authors but it's is it's a
cool new thing and note then there are
like things that move along with with
Jas like SJS evolves are things that we
see in the web platform in browsers that
we think yeah that might be close my for
note like standard URL object like it's
a good I think it's becoming a global in
know tense like you can just like take
URL new URL just like you write it in
the browser and use that same thing in
note text occur the text text encoder
those things then there's things that
are coming from the JavaScript engines
so themselves like we are currently in
master and so probably in no 10 as well
on v8 6.4 which means like stuff like
we're full assembly support in there
that's pretty cool we have a like I
don't know if you have ever heard of
that but like the old debugger way API
there that went completely away but we
also like since then we introduced as a
replacement a way to talk like the like
you can talk to node like the v8 chrome
debugger like you probably have used
that with not or I've heard that you can
do that it's like there's an API for
talking to node with that so like you
can actually do really cool things like
inspect the actual stack of your program
while it is running not just a stack
Chris but like the actual variables and
everything it's like pretty cool stuff
that you can build with that
we're changing the era system in note
yeah I'm gonna like have more details on
everything in here later so I like some
more longer Ford's okay so yes modules
um I'm just like gonna give an overview
of where like my understanding of where
we are at this and I think my understand
is pretty accurate but I'm not like a
like 2 F we recently we span up a new
modules working group and like if you
are really really interested in like
knowing what exactly is being discussed
and it's happening you can like they
have meetings and they are being
recorded and you might want to check
those out there there is experimental
support in notes so like you can run
note - - experimental modules I think
something like that and you actually can
use ESM with that and it's not quite
where you want it to be yet it's like
one of the things that that we're
currently having a notice that that mgs
is happening as the file extension for
ES modules that might not have to be the
end of it there might be a way to like
use ESM with GS files we're just like
gonna have to gonna have to see what we
can make happen what like is actually
best for everyone it's like one of the
things about us modules is that in every
discussion there's always like multiple
approaches and like none is perfect and
like it always has real downsides for
everyone and like like I can't go into
detail mostly because like some of those
thoughts like for example one of the
things that I have here and the list of
stat named imports was CGS for command
GS so like you can yeah we right you're
at a module that's called like left pad
or something and so you want to like imp
and then import the actual fraction I
don't know what it's called import pad
from coming from left pad or something
like that it's not like going to be what
you it might work it might not work and
like it's not as easy as saying okay we
can just make it work it's like it's
also going to be very different from
what you have right now with commands
yes it's like it's being loaded
asynchronously
so like that's one of the issues that we
have like with interoperability so like
you can't just require and yes module
that's like never going to actually work
this require always gives you a
synchronous result and that is just like
not happening with yes modules by design
it's also not not going to work like
babel like currently compiles yes
modules just like probably one of the
more tricky things to work around it
might be good enough but like babel
isn't doing it like the like this back
wants us to so like we're gonna have to
do it like the the actual j aspect wants
us to do it so yeah okay so like just
like to give a quick overview it's like
important FS from FS just like importing
the entire module that is going to work
that currently does work we like four
core modules we're also going to have
named imports in some way like most
likely because like at least there are
ways that we can make it happen
so yeah and imparting like between
exists between userland
yes modules is always going to work
right that's just like completely SPECT
and yeah that's not going to be an issue
what you like weird what we're not going
to have in yes modules underscore
underscore file name or underscore
underscore their name something like
that i instead you're going to get the
URL of the current module and all of
that lives under imported media so like
there's no magic Global's like all right
she was like require or module or
experts or anything like that and you're
probably going to get like imparted
meter that require which like it's going
to give you way to at least lot existing
common J's modules in in USM okay
another thing HTTP to which is like as I
said is something that I've been working
on a lot more than USM and it's really
cool we have like pretty much everything
in the API fleshed out right now so
that's nice we are it's currently
experimental it has been since it was
introduced in think one-and-a-half years
ago I don't remember exactly but it's
like with your hope is that in no 10
which is like one month away it's not
going to be experimental anymore mostly
because like the API is really fleshed
out at this point it's a lot like the
there is a compatibility API so you can
use it a lot like HTTP one or the
existing HTTP module if you want to
that's going to be useful a lot of the
time you can actually like at least if
you're using TLS servers you can
actually build build servers that
support both natively which is really
nice but likely the new API that you get
from HTTP to if you if you don't care
about like the old stuff about HTTP 1
it's a lot cleaner than what we have an
HTTP 1 yeah it's it's just like it's
also just like better code like actually
everyone was like written in a time when
there was a lot smaller and and it was
just like there was less command review
and more like ok yeah we're gonna like
make changes and like if something
breaks and we're gonna fix it yeah so it
was a different time and plus you get
all the perks of HTTP 2 which is like
you can have a single connection and
multiplex different screams like
basically different files over that you
get pushed
it's like I'm not exactly sure like how
people are actually going to use it but
I'm pretty sure that they're going to
build amazing stuff with it and so like
this is a basically sample of like how
an HTTP server looks like you're gonna
see that like this is not the
compatibility API this is like the
actual new one and you're gonna see okay
some things are pretty familiar like
creating a server and listening on a
port that works like like you'd expect
it to but instead of like requests you
had screens it's like kind of
conceptually the same thing it's like an
HTTP to scream it's like an actual
writable stream that you can just send
data to and instead of like writing
headers you conceptually those are kind
of similar but like you can yeah it's
just like pretty similar if you look at
it at that but like it has a much richer
API but you're gonna have to look at it
up in the documentation if you actually
want to know a lot about that okay so
one of the things that I also like find
pretty cool in notice async works
that's way to like get more of an idea
of what is currently happening in the in
those event loop like what what things
are keeping the event will be life and
what things are currently running so
like for example if you're reading a
file you could actually use s in hooks
to tell what file requests are currently
going on and so also a API that allows
you to like keep track of what a same
thing is causing what async things like
for example some people have previously
built stuff like continuation local
storage with the previous thing that we
had for it which was domains which is
like not a great idea it's like what
we're getting rid of it and that
basically means okay for example you can
you can keep track of what where your
current code is like to watch HTV tu h
here HTTP requests it originally belong
to and like just like keep track of that
and see which where that origin it came
from and you can can you can use it for
like diagnostics for looking at the
timing of operations it's still
experimental and it has a lot of rough
edges in its API I'm gonna give an
example like pretty much right now and
just so you know if you're writing
add-ons ladyhood add-ons like note
doesn't automatically know what you're
doing like if you're just like calling
back from from C++ are from C you're
just like not know doesn't know where
where that originally was caused in note
in the J's code it's like as an add-on
author you're going to have to support
it like pretty much explicitly okay and
so this is like one example script so
like icing hooks that means you have
four hooks it means like you get an
inner took a before after and destroy
hook just like keeping track of of like
every single async operation that is
happening for like for like sockets you
so like if there's an inbound connection
the inner talk is called every time
there is an event on that socket before
and after hooks are called and like once
that socket close it is it gets up to
destroy hook that has been called so I I
have like reading the current file as an
example here at the at the end of this
quick and so like what that actually
does is okay so the first thing it's
initializing AFS request grep that gets
the IV what is that oh it's the ID six
it's like it's like numerical IDs that
you're using to keep track of everything
then later in that script the before
hook is called which means that that
request is finished then it's
initializing in other another file
system request gets to the next ID which
is seven and then the original one is
finished like it's after and destroy
hooks are called
then later the same thing for the next
request like it it's finished it calls
its call back just like indicated by
having it before and after
ok and because it's a request like
request means it only like it's when
it's finished it's done it's always
getting called it's calling the destroy
hook and finally you get another friend
system request and it's like this is
just like the beginning so like it's
very very detailed but what you can
actually see is that there are different
things happening here it's like the
first is actually opening the file the
second one is actually reading from the
file and the third one is closing the
file request so like it's very very low
level and very detailed but yeah you can
build pretty cool stuff with it one of
the things that are also like in the
area of things that are pretty cool in
the web platform and we're having
compatibility is nice it's perfect
performance 6 it's it's also like I
don't think it's introduced in node 8
and I think it's still experimental too
but like also slowly getting out of that
I might be right might be stable by now
and yet this is just like Department
performance API like you have it in the
browser if you're ever I've come in
touch with that it's like you have
performance that now and and a lot more
in there like support for no just
specific events like you can actually
actually tell like how long it took to
lot load the main module of your
application and everything and and it
gives you like low overhead timers which
is like we have something something
similar with like console that time and
console that time and but this is this
is a cool new stuff ok an API who in
this room has ever written a native
add-on with note it's not a lot of
people so if you ever like felt that
that might be useful for you this is a
cool new thing that also makes that a
lot easier
like if you previously wrote an add-on
for note you have to understand the v8
API which is dual but really really
tricky because like if you're coming
from a JS background there error
handling is just like going to be really
really confusing because like it's
written in C++ and they don't use
exceptions it's like that has
performance impact so they're gonna have
to do something really really tricky and
with napi you have something pretty
natural so like this is an example of
how to write a C++ add-on with an API
this is just a single function that you
can expose to JavaScript and I mean it's
it's not quite like JavaScript you still
have like to do things like explicitly
convert like say this value convert it
to a number and then like give me the
value as a 32-bit integer that's
overhead you're not gonna get it around
but I get like as a JavaScript developer
you can definitely understand what this
does and make changes to it and yeah
it's okay another thing promise support
is just like something that we're going
to live with like there are people who
don't really like to use promises in
node and like they're going to keep
being able to do that but like generally
people are going to use async await
people are going to use promises for a
lot of stuff and yeah we as a platform
know just like has to move along with
that and so like we have like if you
don't use async await at this point you
should just like telling you this is
just like really really really nice you
have we have a weight support entity in
the wrapper right now I think that's
also just like coming out in no 10
because like we actually have to like do
some weird transpiration inside the
repple like previously previously didn't
do that
but we think it's
it's like we have to ship an actual like
parsing library with note we have Google
dot promise if I in Note 8 and above
which is like the bare minimum like you
can convert note functions to like
promise api's but just like you still
have to do that explicit conversion
which is not that nice we have a new
module FS / promises coming in no 10 and
that is actually going to be like all
the file system functions that you're
used to
except they work promise based and like
instead of so instead of file
descriptors like the actual you're
working with like if you're using file
descriptors in the current file system
API you're working with the actual raw
numbers which is not that nice piece
like I mean you can open a file and
basically forget to close it and just
like it's going to leak resources if you
are not really really careful
like if something throws before you can
close the file the file descriptor
you're gonna have a resource leak it's
like there's the one change that is
different from the normal FS API that
you don't actually work with your raw
file descriptors to work with wrappers
and like if you if they get garbage
collected they're going to show you a
warning it's like hey you forgot to
close this that's also pretty nice and I
think iterators which is like something
that I think is like you don't need a
flag for it in no.10 anymore like just
to have the the engine exposed to us and
like we're going to implement that in
some way for for redline and for screams
it's like you can actually do something
like for racing cons shank off-screen
instead of like listening to the data
event of a stream also like really
really cool and so like yeah I mentioned
in the beginning that there were changes
to our error system and it's like every
error in node is going to eventually
have a error code associated with it in
some way
this is usually going to look something
like this like this is just like a very
simple example of use like passing in a
just like invalid thing to a function
like you can't listen on an array with a
network server just like going to tell
you okay yeah that is not the right form
we don't understand that and it's like
so you can use you can look up the error
code on that on that error
yeah and that also means like if you're
currently like the motivation for this
is that like a lot of people were
checking the the error text the error
message when they like to figure out
what actually happened and just like do
like diagnostic speak in terms of that
and that's not really cool because that
means that changing an error message is
actually a cember major change or has
been up until now and we really don't
want to do that group on I like just
like give you the best error messages we
can it's like yeah if you're if you want
to know what was happening with a
certain error just use error that code
from now but like also like introducing
this as always the same verb major
change or at least we consider the one
just like to be careful at this point so
this is just like more of a long-term
thing too and yeah okay workers we it's
like there was a fork of node that you
made a furtive like a while ago like
half a year or so and in there I
actually build work your support for
node and I mean that far can installed
at this point but but I have a lot of
free time in the next couple weeks and I
definitely want to have this a node I'm
gonna try to like take the parts which
like half a year olds like I mean
there's those are pretty big patches but
like I definitely want to have to add a
note and like when I get them part it
and want to make that happen really soon
like that is what the API would
currently look like if those patches
were accepted as they currently are it's
like completely up for debate but
yeah you could just like have work as a
note and those would have like access to
the full noches API it's not like we're
workers where you like have only
restricted subset of things if if you
want that you can probably build it with
this like this is like speculative it's
like there there isn't even open pull
request so like take it with like grain
of salt are you all tired at this point
just like I know this is I know this is
a very technical talk it's like doesn't
really have any highlights or anything I
hope you're fine with that I ain't like
the general ideas just like to give you
an overview over it's happening and I
mean if you want to look something up
again you can always like take a look at
these slides later or or ask me or
anything which is like don't feel like
you have to like soak everything out
just like no okay webassembly is there
and we should have probably heard of
because like over the last two months or
so like everybody has been really really
excited about being able to use rap
assembly in JavaScript it's like yeah we
have support for that it's not gonna
like completely replace native add-ons
but going to replace a lot of the use
cases that we have for those yeah also
like since no date you we like like I
guess a lot of people here that are
using the new protection are still on
note 6 or something like that no date
has a completely new compiler tool chain
which is like I think like people were
seeing up to 50% increases in
performance just like from having this
new JavaScript compiler tool chain like
yeah I read work that they did or like I
said the debugger API if you're ever
used that it's like gone because like V
I'd remove that so like we can't provide
it anymore we're gonna have to live with
what's coming up scream
and oh yeah right it's we also like
managed like it's not really a spur like
we ain't decided to put note in its own
CI so like that means that every change
to v8 is actually being run against note
and see whether it breaks any of our
tests which is like really really nice
first ability and just like not having
to worry about as much like putting
putting as much work into upgrading the
18 note because like they're also like
trying to take care of that on their own
some are longer turn things okay so
chakracore
is it's a fork if note that's still like
pretty actively being worked upon i'm
not sure like when they're trying to
like get that into the main noches
repository but they they do have
releases that you can check out like you
can't install them i mean i think there
are things like nvm with which you can
install them but like i don't think you
can do it with nvm itself in any case
you can just like download and run them
and see what whether that's for you
whether it works i mean like if if you
want try it out and if you have any
feedback they'd be happy about that i
guess also like good and this is I just
like added that last night because like
we had our TOC meetings you see meeting
yesterday after the party and okay so
our like we're gonna have to look at the
OpenSSL story because so currently we're
using open SSL 102 and that is going to
stop being supported after 2019 it's
like it's it's already limiting like how
far we can support note 8 because we're
using that they're like usually we would
support no date for 4 more months I
think I think it's like we have to end
that early because like open mrs. Ellis
going out of LTS and so like the most
probable outcome is that we're going to
support like three versions of OpenSSL
EndNote it's like still going to take a
lot of work
in no.10 and it's like that's why I said
like it's very very likely that no 10 is
coming out in April but like there's
also the option of just waiting for
OpenSSL 1 1 1 to come out which is
probably going to be in May and just
like waiting for that with Aurelius we
don't really want to do that because
like we already delayed like the last
like Note 8 not a release for a
dependency we don't want to kind of get
in the habit of that and we're probably
going to make this work some way but
yeah and openness will be one one one is
actually coming with TLS 1.3 support
which is like I don't know if you care
about that but like people who do a lot
with security stuff apparently care so I
guess that's a really good thing yeah
okay one more thing we like also one of
the things that we just decided this
week is that we are actually going to do
a runtime deprecation for like the
buffer constructor for new buffer or
without the new in some way in no.10 I
rewrote it on that and just like it's a
decision that we're going to have to
live with the backward controller has
been deprecated since note 6 so like
it's been quite a while but people are
still very actively using it and there
are some like I don't know if you've
ever read up on that there are some
usability concerns that like reach into
security issues so like the thing is and
if you like use pass the string to to
the buffer yeah I actually have an
example it's like if you have input
that's coming from a user and you're
going to like parse it in some way and
you forget validating the type and then
you're going to respond something with
with new buffer where the parameter is
something that you didn't really
validate so like that that thing that
you think
some screen like which it might not be
because the user passed it in like if
that's a number like in other versions
of nerd you would actually get a chunk
of additional uninitialized memory it's
like you would actually tell you
potentially tell an attacker what is in
your memory which is like something you
really don't want to do and so like we
switch to zero filling a while ago it's
like you they would get a zero foot
buffer but still like they could like if
there's an attacker and they can control
your program like that and they pass in
a really big number like your program is
trying to use a lot of memory and that's
actually it's like if they do it that a
couple times your code it's just like
we're going to run out of memory yep
your servers going to crash we don't
want to have that happen so we
deprecated the buffer constructor and
replaced it with buffered Alec and
buffer that from you should use those
and like there's going to be a warning
and emitted in no.10 like I said in some
way and be careful and like try to
upgrade your code if you have new buffer
anywhere in there it's like you don't
want your users or yourself to just like
be you see a warning every time you run
that code another thing that is like
kind of thought somebody was saying
something ok yeah screams so that's also
one of the more long-term things but
it's like what I basically spent my last
four or five months working on the node
so like scripts have a lot of overhead
it's like there's buffering in on both
sides for readable screens for writable
screams there's support for a lot of
stuff in there that most people like
well they do use it but they don't use
it all the time like automatically
decoding incoming data from like buffers
to utf-8 or something it's like it's a
very complex machinery you have a lot of
different modes to use screams in just
like it's very complex and it does
unfurnished you unfortunately have a lot
of overhead it's
not terrible but like it's not the way
it should be so like a couple people are
working on like flashing out a new
low-level screams API that is not going
to have those issues it's probably going
to be pull screen based and it's like
what I did it's like that that is still
very speculative what I actually did and
landed a note is like a lot of
refactoring on the C++ side of things
and so like the goal of that is being
able to like have scream a the pipe
scream be just like half that be a fast
path just like not calling into
JavaScript screams at all just like
passing the data right through in C++
which is like if I can make that work
it's going to be really really fast and
so just like so you know where bad note
4 is just like about to expire like if
you use node 4 anywhere just like get
rid of that because like it's only
supported for another month node 6 is
being supported until like one more year
which is also like you might want to
think about starting to move away from
that and like I said no it is supported
on 30 December 2019 because like open
SSL expires then one or two no.9 is like
also like I mean like when I'm talking
to people like some of them are not that
aware that like our our odd number
releases like node 7 node 5 node 9 like
they're just like they basically stop
being supported when the next major
release comes out like no 10 we're still
going to do security releases for like
another two months or so but basically
like if you use an odd-numbered release
of node that's cool because like you
should because like it's basically a a
peek into the future
but yeah it's just like if you're using
that just like be prepared to jump to
know ten like very very soon and that's
it thank you for listening if you have
any questions just like you can come to
me if you have anything that note could
do better or that we could do better or
that you want to change a note yourself
just like come talk to me
[Applause]